Okay, still lots of people coming in here.
Welcome to another Zoom call, everybody.
A few questions that came in, so we'll get to that.
Remind her again.
Please make sure you go to the member site.
That's where you're going to find anything you need.
Order labs, go to the group site to get labs.
If you need help like you need help like what lab should I order?
Just email me at labs.com or through an email that we sent you.
And I will send you a link to do that.
Also, if you can, we really do need from a legal standpoint
that you complete the coaching call request form.
I know sometimes people aren't doing that because we could
call for people and it's nobody on this call.
But we could call for people that started with us a couple of years ago
and they're doing great, so they haven't logged into the member site for ever.
If ever.
So just missing out on some information that could be beneficial for you.
So we just want to encourage people to do that and remember to do that.
OK, I don't think we need to go over any more information
about the true right software updates.
If you haven't updated your computer as of right now,
probably just wait and tell we need to tell the seventh put is out.
But if you are really techy and you want to get your software
community things and contact the clinic and we go over some information
about how you could do that.
OK, let's jump into the questions.
I recently completed 25 sessions of radiation treatment with 50 grads.
I think that's a grads, humans have dosage, colorectal tumor.
There are some side effects like painful to pass stool, some prostate,
pain also, burning, well, urination, that well hydrated.
So these are negative effects of radiation on other tissue.
Now, the negative, the positive of doing radiation therapy
is that where it's going to hit in the distinct dosage is going to cause cell death.
And that's what we want, we want cell death of the cancer.
But where it's going to be diffused, it's going to cause cell damage.
And when they're cell damage, then you end up with side effects of that cell damage.
So you want to do everything you can to try to heal those cells.
And so what do you do?
So is it just a matter of trying to use detox protocols to detox the radiation?
Well, I think that is necessary and you shouldn't do that.
But you have to support the cells that were damaged.
So if so that goes cell, cell line, my cell line.
So in this case, how do you support cells that were damaged in the intestinal tract
without, you know, supporting growth of cells in the intestinal tract?
I would say using products that you would use to help feel the gut that have low amounts of glutamine in it.
Things like, okay, so let me just pull something up here for you to help understand this a little bit.
So, so like our clear GI product, our clear GI product is the reason why I like that product is because it has,
I don't know, pull it up here so you can see it.
So it does have glutamine in it, but it has has 1.5 grams of glutamine.
And I tell, this is per table spoon and I tell people the answer that are taking this because they need to shield their gut to only do a teaspoon at a time.
So you're only getting 500 milligrams of glutamine, which is an acceptable dose of glutamine.
But it has these other things you can find other products on the market.
In fact, you might have some in your cupboard that have some of these other things modified citrus pectin right there can be helpful to bind radiation, but it could also be helpful to help heal the gut.
D glycerized licorice, so D glycerized licorice could be very healing to the gut.
Many products are, you can find on the market that just have de glycerized licorice DGL, it's abbreviated.
That is very healing to the gut.
Although VARA extract is very healing to the glyceric, slippery, elm, marshmallow, cannabelle, ochre, cat's claw.
Cat's claw is helpful for any bacteria in the gut.
MSM is an anti-inflammatory for the gut.
Quercetin and inflammatory for the gut.
So those are the things that you would think about taking for the gut.
This product, you might have another product that has these things that I just thought of this one.
This question was asked so I pulled it on.
So also this person said they're having issues with prostate.
So then you think of prostate products that are going to help.
So using the prostate supreme or our prostac clear product would be great things to do.
You need to support the systems that are damaged.
So if you had radiation to the chest with breast cancer and you're having lung issues, then you think of corniceps, you think of our.
Our clear lung product.
Things that are going to help detoxify the lungs themselves help heal the lung tissue themselves.
So depending on what organ what tissue is damaged, that's what you go after is for the nutritional perspective to try to heal that.
In general, what do you recommend to heal the body any non cancer cells affected with this type of treatment.
So I explain that I understand high dose vitamin C also helps some people suggest that raw vegan food may not be good after such treatment.
Well, this is what we've talked about before multiple times.
You know, you hear about this so often like every cancer patient should go on a raw food diet every cancer patient should start juicing raw vegetables and start just drinking that that's going to cure you.
This is not true. These are just statements that maybe that would be great. A raw food diet might be great if you're 22 years old, but if you're 44 years old, raw food diet, I really difficult to digest.
You have the radiation in the colon area and you have the history of colon cancer, therefore the radiation.
A raw food diet is going to be even more difficult because you already have compromised to the colon. It's going to be more irritating.
So I would not suggest a raw diet or juiced or anything like that cooked vegetables are the way to go.
I've talked about this before when people have really damaged guts, they go on what's called a gaps diet where you're just basically making soup and you know cooking it all day long.
Already very pre-digested and easy to break down for your gut and you're drinking the broth of the soup. So you're vegetable broth and some of the meat broth that can be chicken soup or something.
That is the mildest on the gut that is really helpful to start healing. So I would suggest radiation to the colon, raw food diet, absolutely not.
A very cooked food diet, a gaps type diet, a soup type diet would be the best thing for a period of time to help that heal.
So yeah, I would not suggest that. I think that would be more irritating harder to heal and cause more problems.
I'm looking at the grounding products. Is there a benefit to getting the grounding sheet over the grounding mat.
Good question. Why would you use the grounding sheet or the grounding mat? What's what's the better one to buy?
So the grounding sheet is a different material. So here's the grounding sheet. So the grounding sheet is a very lightweight material that's got the fibers in it that will then go back through this wire that you attach this wire, that section right there to the sheet.
It's got a snap to it, but then this goes to the wall ground out to the ground in the ground.
This is a very lightweight material that's easy to sleep on and doesn't, you know, you're stuck in an irritator body and cause you any health as far as sleep goes.
And you get you put this like we talked about last week, just done the lower half of your bed across your whole bed.
It's a pretty big piece of material. So we have people that get this and use this not just will have even on their bed because you put it underneath your fitted sheet so you don't have to take it off.
So it stays on there permanently.
But people use this and just sit on this as a grounding pad too.
The difference between the two is the grounding pad is made up of a different material. So here's the material for the grounding pad.
So it's more of like a foamy type material. So it looks better on a chair. So typically you use a grounding pad for daytime use on a chair and use the grounded sheet on your bed.
You could use the grounding pad on your bed to, but that's typically not the purpose of it. But to be honest, I have had people get this and use this other other chair to discover their chair with it or they can fold it up and sit on it and
You can use it anyway. They both plug into the wall with a thing like this the same way. They both have the same basically operation. The grounding sheet is going to cover a greater amount of your body. If you're rolling around in bed and such.
So it's just different application, but they do the exact same thing.
Our animal foods really that bad during the helium stage of a cage stage for cancer.
And if it's grass bed free rolling meat. So yeah, there's again, you look on Instagram or Facebook or you do a search on it. You're going to see even practitioners that will bad both animal products big time and that everybody needs to go on a vegan diet or you know, like we've talked about.
And that is just false information. It's just wrong. Most of the people that are telling this have, you know, don't don't have any substantiations to their claims.
A lot of the practitioners that tell this of course they happen to be vegans themselves. They've never had cancer and they've never treated anybody with cancer.
Again, I've said over and over for the last 25 years every person is different.
Some people animal products can feed a cancer at a period of time, especially if their cancer is heavily fed on amino acids at a period of time, but you know that that changes it can change.
Cancer is always trying to find a fuel source.
You know, one of the bad things about eating animal products. What it's a bad thing about eating meat. The answer is nothing's bad about eating meat.
So if you didn't have cancer, you should be eating meat. I am not in favor of even a person without cancer being on a vegetarian or vegan type diet.
There's a lot of people are doing it for different belief systems. Now I don't think that's healthy way to go.
You need protein with serious disease like cancer in order to develop lymphocytes in order to create T cells and
you were controlling white blood cells that are going to kill cancer. So you need meat at some point in time.
Now, again, everybody's different. What's the best way to get meat? Yes, grass fed, free rowing natural fish that's wild caught. Yes, there's inherent problems with any food source whatsoever.
So there isn't anything these days that is perfectly clean. So if you know the farmer that you're getting your food from, it's going to be much better.
But again, every person's different getting tested is really important. Are there specific indications or parameters that is blood that allows a discovery of cancer in an early stage? And what are these parameters or indications?
And our indications are parameters different for each kind of cancer. Okay, well, that speaks to something I was just talking to my staff about today because I haven't seen these Instagram posts in the space of posts.
Say really nice little infographic that says what blood tests can find, you know, 20 different cancers or 12 different cancers. I don't remember what it said.
And it was a very nice looking infographic and I thought, was there something else on the market? So I've been on it and clicked on it.
And it was talking about tumor marker testing, which told me that that infographic and whoever is putting it out and I didn't go any deeper to find out who was publishing this or paying for the ad. It was, um, it was, um,
very misleading to the point of, um, it's just a lot of you can't diagnose cancer with a tumor marker test. So you, I have a blog post on tumor workers. I'm very big into using tumor markers as a way to help you have another not invasive indication of, you know, tracking your cancer can be beneficial.
If you're, if your cancer is showing positive tumor markers, then you can use that to help track your cancer.
You never use one test alone. Nothing stands on itself. Nothing is a perfect gold standard.
Um, but to say that you would, you would do a tumor marker test. And if those were negative, if those were all in range that you don't have cancer.
Oh my gosh, that's like male practice. It truly is because a person, you know, how many people have staged for cancer and all their tumor markers are within range because a lot of cancers don't show positive to workers at all.
Um, and, you know, some typically will like PSA is a to work for prostate cancer almost to everybody with prostate cancer is going to have elevated PSA.
But there's a, there's a large percentage of women with breast cancer that are not going to have elevated CA 19, nine or CA 15, three or CA 125.
So they're not going to have elevated tumor markers and they could have stage for breast cancer.
So, um, to say that a, do you do a blood test and do a tumor marker test and it's negative in that you don't have cancer is bullish.
It can be an early indicator. Um, so getting it like, oh, I'm just curious. I don't feel well and, and my mom at cancer and my dad at cancer. So I want to know to run a tumor marker panel.
It can give you some indications, but it's just one test and don't be, you know, don't go off of one test and think that you don't have cancer. And likewise, you can have elevated tumor markers and you don't have cancer.
So there's other things that could elevate two markers.
We can't remember what to see out there. There's a lot of misinformation.
And yet, you know, I feel like we take such a balanced approach and yet Google and YouTube hate us and just don't get it.
But well, alternative options to add to aromatase inhibitor.
So what are some alternative and this, I think the next question ties into that too.
What can I do to avoid taking the horrible blocker, which is an aromatase inhibitor after surgery and breast cancer.
Yeah, I have some blog posts on different aromatase inhibitors.
And again, no aromatase, you know, no natural aromatase inhibitor is going to act like the drug. So the drug is going to basically shut down all your estrogen and progesterone.
And that's why women hate it because you just, you have no estrogen progesterone.
And it's really just that one group of estrogens or progesterone that is the culprit in horrible and positive cancer.
But then all estrogens seems to be like, you know, there's a sniper in New York City, so we'll hit it with an atomic bomb and we'll kill the sniper.
Well, I guess you will, but you just used, you know, SWAT team could you do the same thing and not kill 30 million people along with the sniper.
You know, that's the question that you have to, the decisions that you have to make natural aromatase inhibitors are going to decrease bad estrogens.
Not as quickly, not as beneficially as completely as a drug.
And you have to weigh out the pros and cons of that. A lot of people will use the drug for a short period of time and then switch to natural.
And they've reduced the estrogen enough to really shut down the cancer.
Our cancer cure statistics accurate. Well, we don't have any statistics. You know that.
From a medical legal standpoint, we can't keep track of statistics medical cancer cure statistics. I go over this in detail in my book.
You, you, you statistic through the American Medical Association with cancer is based upon the date of diagnosis.
So if I was diagnosed in 2020, April of 2020 with cancer.
If I lived till April, second, 2025, the better, how, you know, the quality of my life in those five years by live one day after the five year date of diagnosis goes by, I put down as a statistic of cured.
So that's how those statistics work. And you could say that those are really rubber numbers. They are. You could say that that's really an unfair way to do things. It is, but it's very difficult to, to, to clarify that.
How do you say somebody is sure to cancer? Well, when they don't have, you know, anything, when they have no evidence of disease on a PET scan, when they have no evidence of disease on an MRI or CT scan.
You know, that's one way, but, you know, then a year later, now they have the pastysis and they have evidence of disease.
Because a PET scan and an MRI CT scan, you know, not going to show cancer unless it's over three million cells large. So it doesn't mean they don't have cancer still. That's why I say don't stop using your right, don't stop doing your therapies.
But, um, so how do you, how do you define that in the medical industry, those that you can't really define it that way. So we're just going to go based on whether you live five years post diagnosis.
And of course, the problems with that is that you could have lived a horrible life and you die one day afterwards and they still put you know this, sure.
Now the other website of that is that if you don't go through their, their portal, if you don't stay in contact with, you know, with an oncologist, if you kind of stepped out of that field and you're doing alternative things.
How they keep you track of anybody. So are they just assuming that you live five years and they're putting you down as cured. I don't know, I don't know where this is being kept track of.
I don't know of any portal that exists. I've never seen it in writing where an oncologist is supposed to keep track of the date of diagnosis and the five years years later.
I don't think that exists. I don't think there's a nationwide.
You know, medical portal site that is time based tracking date of diagnosed five years later if that person's still alive.
Quite honestly, I don't think that exists, which makes me think that a lot of these numbers are kind of made up.
And especially, you know, you don't choose to do standards of care. You're not, how did they even know if you lived or died. What are they doing? They got a nurse looking at obituaries every day. I mean, I don't think so. So how is any of these statistics even, you know, kept up.
We have people that contact us. We haven't heard from them for 10 years and they contact us, you know, out of the blue. You know, we have to like I started off this conversation and we have to explain to them. Hey, now we have a member site. You need to get on this and this happens every week.
Almost and that Marine is literally having to get a person on the member site that, you know, they haven't contacted us for years. We didn't even know if they were still around.
And that's okay because we're not trying to create this dependency on us. We want you to be independent and really we want to be interdependent so that you do have us as a resource when you need us.
But we're not trying to create a unhealthy dependence that you have to stay in contact with us. So we want people to be educated and feel like they could go off on their own. It's got an email yesterday from somebody who I haven't heard from since he started three and a half years ago. So it's
that's okay. You know, but how would the medical field know and keep those statistics. I just don't think they just don't think it actually happens. So no, that's, that was a long answer for are they are these statistics reliable. No, I don't think so.
Okay, questions come in on the chat when I read out my eye on pro wave after each you sometimes I get a pretty good size chunks of rusty metal that fall out like a flat one inch piece and it seems to be working. So don't worry about it.
If it's working and how you'll know that I am probably isn't working is that way, every time I used to use it, it used to turn really, you know, this color and now it doesn't just seem like it just calls unchanged and it's like not not changing turning that color anymore.
Then it's time to replace it. So they they last anywhere between 50 and 120 uses.
Depending on the quality of your water at home and so you just need to order and do what if you get to that point. So I wouldn't worry about it if it seems to be working.
Since the right update three or four of my daily programs won't run, I get an error message about the duty. Okay, so then I will have to fix that.
So wait till the January fix of those then. So yeah, planning then to have the updates cheeks on that. Yeah, I would just wait till that.
Ever heard of Fred Hughes and or doctor Rob Dowling in regarding dental toxins and cancer.
I've read several books on dental toxins dental, you know, root canals and cancer and they're tied to cancer quite I can't remember the authors.
So in these might be more recent. That was a number of years ago that I did that.
But definitely, I would say that I would agree with probably anybody that's talking about dental toxins and cancer and vaccinations and cancer and things like that because it's just there is definitely a tie to those best way to get rid of visceral fat.
My surgeon says I have a little bit that I need to get rid of. I still eat your diet protocol fast 16 eight eat stevia monk fruit set of sugar, maybe 10 pounds overweight.
I would caution you to do anything different.
You know, if you're doing all the right things and you carry a little extra visceral fat do not think that some textbook BMI is perfect for you, everybody's a little bit different.
At least healthy people throughout all my years of practice have been those that have been very thin and so it's I am just not the fate of trying to stay to some level of perfection.
You do what is right. And if you carry a little extra visceral fat, that's just perfectly fine. I would say don't worry about being 10 pounds overweight.
The only person should be weighing themselves. I think is if you're in if you think you're in a state of coquexia, you want to make sure that you're not losing too much weight.
It's not a block grounding for a grounded pattern chair, even a grounded sheet. Yes, and no, so it depends on how much clothing you have.
And it depends on what clothing what kind of clothing it is, the more synthetic, the clothing, the more it will block the grounding.
So it's obviously better to have a skin to a grounded pad contact. And I will tell you, we have some people that use the grounding sheet as a over the top.
I said, you know, and it's what it's recommended is to put it underneath the fitted sheet. I have some people put it on top of the fitted sheet. So they're laying on top of it.
I have had some people over time put the grounded sheet over them in different areas, using it during the day to protect them, and they have to sit at a
tutor, and they feel like they're in an area they live in the cities or something where they're getting a lot of eMFs. I've had people that would get a eMF meter and just read where their office is is really super high at eMFs, and they'll put the grounding sheet over the top of them.
So there's all sorts of different ways to use it. The point is though, really, remember, what is the purpose of grounding you are picking up positive ions from eMFs from electrical dirty electricity in your house from
everything in the world you're picking up these positively charged ions. The idea of grounding is that you want to disperse them with a balance of negatively charged ions and you get the best source of negatively charged ions is the earth itself. You go out in the yard.
You don't need a grounding pad to sit on all day if you walk it out in the yard every day and you're going for a short walk and touching the ground and dispersing those. If you have a dog that you let outside and he's running around outside in the yard and then you come in and you hug the dog, you're basically dispersing all those electrons.
If you think of it as an electrical charge and that you're trying to disperse that electrical charge, that's probably the best way to get it into your head that way.
It's not a matter of you need to stay grounded 24-7 hours a day or you're going to have these horrible negative effects. It's the accumulation of these that isn't dispersed.
So if you can think of it that way, that would be better. Thank you Ed for that clarification on that. We should do that.
I have started using infrared sauna my whole life. I've been terrible sweater.
So I think what you mean you don't sweat well. Most people would say that there are terrible sweater in this world.
You can sweat horribly or terrible sweater could be used this time of year in a ugly Christmas sweater contest. But I know what you mean you don't sweat a lot.
I can sit in the sauna for 20 minutes and 140-145 and barely sweat. If I walk on a treadmill for 30 minutes before getting to the sauna, then I do sweat better.
Do you have any recommendation encouragement for my body to sweat?
Yeah, that is hard. Some people have told me in the past that they just do not sweat. They've never sweat. They don't sweat with their outside.
Those are all bad signs. You need to get your body sweating.
So any of you could do that if you find that walking on a treadmill for 30 minutes and then doing the sauna, I have had people say they don't sweat.
They've gotten the sauna. They don't sweat. And the more that they do the sauna, more frequently, they do the sauna. The more they sweat.
So that you might find that to be true too. So I don't know if you just got the sauna just recently. If that's true, you may find that the more you are doing the sauna, the more you are sweating.
Make sure you're fully hydrated too. So some people don't sweat because they just don't drink water. Their body is just holding fluid.
So make sure you're you're decent, you know, decent hydration too.
I listened to Jade McClellan's talk on the recent cancer summit. She said if you go on a ketogenic diet, you also need to do something to block interleukin six, or you could get kexia.
She said that bivervectin works for this. Have you ever heard of this happening or happening or seated happened to everyone. I haven't heard anything about bivervectin blocking interleukin six. So interleukin six is a inflammatory cytokine.
So it is the so what for the nutritional standpoint will decrease interleukin six is green tea extract is the most powerful thing to decrease interleukin six.
So interleukin six is a inflammatory cytokine. It's what it's covered in a lot of chronic inflammation and chronic inflammatory conditions are threaded conditions.
It is very common with bone loss with osteoporosis osteoporosis is technically a inflammatory condition where you have high amount of interleukin six buildup at the
osteocyte location using green tea extract is really important. And I used to say that green tea extract was the only thing that was that was proven through studies to decrease interleukin six. Well, and I say uses that because at one time that was true.
Recent studies show that hercumid does decrease interleukin six, though not as powerfully. And it has very tall decreases interleukin six.
So again, it's back to the flavonoids that decrease inflammation overall, but it's green tea extract that's the most powerful with interleukin six.
I have not heard about hypervectin working to block interleukin six. So I would be interested in what she said with that study on to look at her election.
One of the most important things to do for EFFs when I look at some suggestions like recall as it seems like a lot inexpensive also what's the point of turning off your wife by your neighbor's wife by say those are also zooming through your house.
If EFFs were a significant problem for our cancer would you have come up with that when you do our cheek swaps.
Yes, I know because EFFs are rarely the cause of a cancer they just they are causes of other ill effects in your body.
They can be disruptive in all body functions in all cancers, but they're rarely the primary cause.
So what can you do about EFFs?
Well, that's very difficult because you're right, if you do turn off your wife, you still have your neighbor's wife, I think you could pick up if they had their password.
However, it's the farther you are away from the source, the, you know, the less effective it's going to have on your body.
You know, I've had people that were really highly sensitive to EFFs and these were more so when I was seeing a lot more live patients, so people that have, you know, some chronic live issues and chronic mold issues.
And many times it's cross the blood brain barrier is caused in the inflammatory process of the brain. If you have an inflammation in the brain, whether it's due to do from limer mold or post compressive syndrome or brain tumors.
Do you have any reason to have an inflammation of the brain that may or may have not have caused what are what's called micro glial primate and you can watch my video on neuro inflammation.
And I think I have several blog posts on that and brain inflammation that will help you understand neuro glial primate.
These people with that are much more sensitive to EFFs.
Because your neural tissue is going to be more affected by EFFs than let's say a breast tumor.
So that's going to be the greater concern for EFFs sensitivity issues.
However, you also have that genetic that C-A-G, whatever N-A-G, I think it is, that if you have a lot of defects on that gene, you're going to be more sensitive to EFFs as well. So I wouldn't noted that in your genetic review.
But if you have brain inflammation of any kind, especially neuro glial primate, you're going to be more sensitive to EFFs.
And I've had people in that category before that have used those sheets.
So take in this sheet because these are fairly large when you open them up and have pinned them up in their bedroom.
So pin them up on the wall behind their bed, pin them up on each wall of their bed bedroom to block EFFs, at least while they're sleeping in one gal who's developing
dementia, early age dementia, this is what I had her do.
And I think it's slow to dementia. That's all what you could really hope for for dementia. So have this, she has one on her bed.
Well, why would you do this? Because it's a groundy cheek. I don't, but with the fibers in there, it blocks EFFs too.
So yeah, that gets to me costly. This is, that would probably be the less costly fix.
There's other things that you could do with whole home, the static, the static products.
So, but that gets expensive too. So like here's the whole, whole EFF thing, but I didn't turn it up. So you can look about the whole whole EFF blockage thing, this thing right here.
Then we have on our website, not have very many people buy that, but this you connect to your wiring.
It's like $1,300 actually saves you electricity because it saves the surge on your, on all your electric products.
So it does pay for itself in a couple of years from your electrical savings.
Bob, but that's, that's forward dirty on electricity. So that's not going to protect you against the neighbors, Wi-Fi and things.
So it does, you know, how many things can you do before you go broke in this thing?
So there's, there's some things you just can't do. So I suggest just take more comments and approach.
I still think it's beneficial turn off your Wi-Fi at night while you're sleeping while you don't need that.
Get your cell phone away from you while you're sleeping.
Put it in the other room, put it in one of our little bags, you know, those little bags made out of this material cost you very little.
So, you know, the Faraday cages are your best bet for things like that.
You make this person, you make baits that tried to make a semi Faraday cage out of her bedroom with these sheets.
So you should have a balance with everything. If you're going to just go overboard and go crazy about it, then, you know, you're, you're getting out of balance.
And just do your best without, you know, causing financial stress in your household.
Emotional stress and anxiety in your own in yourself is awesome.
I am also a poor sweater per consult with developer of Theresage. I sit in my 45 minutes at 165.
That's interesting. So higher temperature for a longer period of time.
Has that helped? I'm interested. Does do you sweat a lot more or is it just the length of time?
It's causing you to, you know, have a greater notice.
Yes, river sweat. Oh, river sweat.
Yeah, I think there's a dance troupe by that name.
Okay, any other questions?
I would agree. You have to work up to a longer period of time.
Like I've said, I don't think I could ever go 45 minutes.
I guess if I really worked on it, but I, I don't have trouble sweating. So you start to feel you have to get out. That's the good piece of advice there.
Alright, I think with that, we will say goodbye. So thanks everybody for being on.
And I exhort everybody to be praying for everybody else.
So sometimes it's good to get our mind off of our self and unto try to help others and praying for others can be a very, very important thing to do for everybody.
I know that I love you. I hope you are not stressing out about Christmas and it's going to be a good season for everyone.
Alright, bye bye.